[Applaudissements]
18h30 sur les champs elysées plus de
2000 personnes ont un téléphone le
sacrifice 3h02 que nous sommes le 28
novembre 2007 ce jour la marque la
sortie en france du tout premier
téléphone apple alors comment expliquer
à celui qui ne connaît pas l'iphone
c'est d'abord un téléphone mais pas
n'importe lequel
il permet d'envoyer et de recevoir des
appels il permet d'envoyer et de
recevoir des sms
il permet d'envoyer et de recevoir des
mails il permet de surfer sur internet
en fait c'est un téléphone oui mais
quand tu l'as tu es quelqu'un qu'un
iphone
il est beau il est cher halo 3 heures
d'attentes pour être parmi les premiers
à l'arborer comme un trophée
399 euros + 49 euros par mois minimum
mais un téléphone pas comme les autres à
cette époque on est encore loin des
téléphones intelligents les smartphones
ok nokia ok ok ok nokia quelques marques
comme motorola samsung nokia ou
blackberry se partagent le marché
le blackberry les mecs ils avaient
réussi à mettre un clavier entier sur un
téléphone portable
c'était super pas pratique quand tu
avais des groupes où ce bref jusqu'à
l'arrivée de l'iphone les téléphones
sont plus ou moins innovante plus ou
moins réussies et plus ou moins bon mais
lorsque le téléphone de la marque à la
pomme débarque mais c'est une révolution
mais un téléphone pas comme les autres
baladeur musical albums photos que l'on
feuillette depuis grâce à un écran
tactile et l'accès à internet illimité
même le pdg de france télécom s'amuse à
jouer les démonstrateurs c'est comme si
vous aviez une peau élastique vous tirer
dessus
ça grandit en plus d'avoir un objet trop
beau trop classe le top et il faut bien
l'avouer c'était l'écran tactile alors
oui ça existe déjà mais là mais là mais
là mais la la ça fonctionnait vraiment
bien tellement bien qu'on utilise tous
des écrans inspiré du premier iphone
c'est aussi l'apparition des
applications en 2007 c'est la première
fois qu'on voyait ça
petite icône tu mets ton doigt dessus et
l'application s ouvre qu'est ce que
c'est beau c'est chouette c'est à apple
c'est la marque à la pomme
même si on était loin des résolutions
d'aujourd'hui l'écran était lui aussi
révolutionnaire pour l'époque ça avait
une définition de dengue 320 par 480 on
pouvait regarder son téléphone comme ça
ou comme ça au le téléphone ils
suivaient le mouvement s'était innovant
c'était magique
c'était beau et c'était tellement facile
à utiliser des points plus faible
apparemment la qualité d'écouté orthez à
l'oreille autre point faible la vitesse
du réseau
par contre il est wi fi ce qui fait
qu'on peut l'utiliser dans un réseau à
la maison ou dans un café à l'époque on
avait beaucoup investi dans l'innovation
chez apple on s'en fout un peu de
l'écouteur le truc le plus surprenant
c'est qu'il n'était même pas 3g edge
ils étaient seulement en edge alors pour
charger une page internet il vous
fallait deux heures dans l'exagèrent
quoique bon vous pouviez utiliser le
wifi mais en 2007 ils n'étaient pas
aussi répandus aujourd'hui oui c'était
un petit peu la loose
il fallait juste se contenter de
quelques applications pas plus y aller
pas encore de app store on pouvait
consulter la bourse
il y avait déjà le google maps il y
avait la météo avait la boîte mail il y
avait des contacts les sms les mms
il avait même pas un jeu il faudra
attendre 2008 pour télécharger les
premières applications
il y avait qu un seul appareil photo on
pouvait pas encore faire de celle fille
enfin signer c'était plus compliqué
c'est peut-être pas la meilleure
invention sur le smartphone le mode
selphy ça n'a pas empêché d'en vendre
beaucoup mais beaucoup en 2009 deux ans
après la sortie de son premier modèle la
marque annonce avoir dépassé ses
objectifs de ventes 13,7 millions
d'iphone dans le monde puis avait juste
prévu d'en vendre que 10 millions en
juillet 2016
on passe le cap des 1 milliard
aujourd'hui on a largement dépassé le
milliard 300 millions à vache a quand
même tendance à faire un beau coup de
téléphone
en fait c'est comme si tous les chinois
avaient un iphone au lieu de ça les
fabriquent
[Rires]
sans abonnement il vous en coûtera 700
49 euros c'est cher mais la marque à la
pomme compte sur l'effet cris qui
caractérise le lancement de chacun de
ses nouveaux produits
[Musique]